what do you make of Liz truss's
departure well it's clear to me now that
the conservatives have no mandate to
continue in government the economic
crisis the British people are facing
with soaring mortgage rates is a direct
consequence of decisions taken in
Downing Street and the idea that Tory
MPS here can stitch up and force upon
the country another Tory prime minister
by fought by denying the British public
any say in that decision whatsoever is
unacceptable people have had enough we
need a government that will clear up
this economic mess stabilize the economy
rebuild our Public Services we need a
general election now
I want to talk about what happens next
in a moment but watching the way that
the conservative party dispatched
Liz truss after 44 days are you a bit
jealous you kept Jeremy corbyn in post
quite a lot longer than that despite
many many of you wanting him gone do you
wish the labor party was a bit more
ruthless like the conservative party is
well Jeremy corbyn was never elected
prime minister and Tori MPS gave us this
Tory prime minister who was responsible
for a disastrous budget which led to a
run on Pension funds and soaring
mortgage rates there are people in my
constituency facing an increasing their
mortgage of hundreds of pounds a month
because Tory MPS gave us the disaster
that was list for us the idea that they
have a mandate to continue into
Government after giving us this crisis
is completely laughable it's why we need
a general election now but Prime
Ministers do change in the middle of a
parliament good Brown became prime
minister in 2007 uh when Tony Blair was
elected at the start of that Parliament
so so yes there is an economic crisis
however it is constitutionally perfectly
fine for this to happen and you'd be
wrong to suggest otherwise well actually
I mean you may be able to correct me but
when in recent history certainly not in
post-war history I don't think have we
had two prime ministers imposed on those
in this particular way actually in 2005
2005 general election the Tory party run
a campaign saying vote Blair get brown
and then and then so you could argue
there was a there was a mandate for that
but but the problem here is that there
is no mandate whatsoever for the
conservative governments to continue to
continue down this line they have given
us a disastrous budget which lets our
run on Pension funds which led to
Soaring mortgage rates and the idea that
the people who caused this mess who
caused this chaos are the people who can
fix it is laughable it's why we need a
general election now because people have
had enough so I suspect we're going to
hear labor figures calling for general
election sort of into level in the face
but the bottom line is you can't make
one happen can you there is an
opportunity if you put down emotional no
competence in the government and you get
enough Tory MPS voting with all the
opposition parties to force one do you
think you're anywhere near to getting
Tory MPS who are absolutely fed up with
this government voting with you and
actually forcing the country to go to
the polls well it's certainly true that
Tory MPS are fed up with their own
government we've seen that played out uh
in the last few days
but are you close to doing evasive no
confidence you know
these conservatives have got an ATC
majority yeah yeah to get a general
election they need to need to decide on
one and a new Thai prime minister coming
in has to accept that they have no
mandate they've just been forced on the
country by Tory and peace the same Tory
MPS who gave us listruss gave us this
disastrous budget who have given us
soaring mortgage rates they have got no
mandate they need to give us a general
election now and I think that is the
view of the British people when I go
around talking to British people there
is a yearning for change out there
because people have had enough of this
lot and they need and want a government
that will come in clear up their Tory
economic mess stabilize the economy and
rebuild our Public Services there's one
element of today that's continuity
rather than change it's quite clear that
Jeremy Hunt for now is going to remain
as Chancellor because of the scale of
the economic problems facing this
country do you think that's the right
decision the scale of economic problems
created by this Tory government yeah the
reason Jeremy Hunt is supposedly looking
at cutting back on support what was what
was until yesterday going to cut the
pension by about 400 pounds on top of
another big cut we've just had this year
in the pension is because he's trying to
clear up the mess created by this
conservative government look I'm not
going to get into whether Jeremy Hunter
should be the chancellor or somebody
else oh I want to see the chancellor it
was Rachel Reeves because we need a
change of government that's why we need
a general election